let me ask you background so before fox
and view what were you doing
really i was i was a teacher i taught um
spanish actually in schools for six or
seven years it's hard to remember
exactly but in new york city in staten
island and in manhattan
um i was a academic dean high school
dean and um interesting when
interestingly went through six flu
seasons and never a mask was mentioned
even though the flu is more dangerous to
kids than covid but that's a side note
but yeah you know i taught in these
schools so when we talk about like woe
curriculums and all of that
oh yeah that's real that's yeah who were
you in high school if we were in high
school together 10th grade who's
jedediah a nerd okay like four point
something gpa valedictorian type of deal
i was the valedictorian of my college
were you ready yeah yeah i went to
wagner college on staten island i got a
4.0 i literally i just worked i was i
was a i was a bookworm so i read a lot
um i was social too i had a lot of
friends i don't know if the definition
of a nerd like what you're thinking of i
wasn't you know ronald miller and uh
can't buy me love do you guys know that
movie it's amazing by the way i had a
crush on him for the longest time i love
you you're dating yourself here i love
nerds though like actual nerds like when
did you break out of your show because
clearly you're not a nerd clearly you're
vocal clearly you got a lot going on so
college i kind of discovered you know
that i had a little bit more of a voice
i you know started dating i started
living uh still was very academic though
at the time i thought i was going to get
a phd in spanish literature i was like i
want to be a professor i love college
campuses this is where i'm going to go
went to columbia got my masters and was
like uh i was wrong colombia yeah so at
that time were you liberal you're where
were you politically i was a
conservative so your parents are they
conservatives
so
yes my dad is very conservative he's
like a ted cruz kind of guy um
my mom is a little bit more of a mixed
bag i think you'd you know i think she's
more of like a marco rubio voter if i
had to peg her as one um
but yeah my family was very eclectic
though my grandparents were democrats um
a lot of family friends that we had in
our house you know as family you know
aunts that weren't really aunts but were
close friends with my mom and whatnot
most of them were liberal and i grew up
in new york city so i was surrounded by
liberalism it just didn't make sense to
me um
so yeah i went to columbia for for a
master's in spanish literature and
decided it wasn't for me that i loved
literature but i i went and worked for
an insurance company for a while um
yeah i do nothing about it i'm a
terrible i mean really like were you
with yourself
zurich zurich i was with zurich but i
did marketing for them i got you but i
mean i used to sell zurich so i remember
zurich yeah i'm not good at that stuff
like if you're gonna ask me about
inflation have another guest on you're
not good i feel like you could be good
at anything you do so what weren't you
good at i'm not i just don't have that
kind of head i'm more of a creative you
know
i'm a creative type you know i want to
sit and write short stories all day long
um
and essentially what happened was i
worked in
waited tables i you know which was one
of the most fun jobs i ever had in my
life and i made a lot of cash so you
know but tough on your feet tough one i
grew got some good guns though that i've
kept from the you know obviously you
can't really see them in here but i
can't see it through the yeah yeah there
it is i mean
i'm just gonna have to take my oh
but floated around for a little while um
went to la thought i might want to do
some acting chickened out was a big
chicken about that shouldn't have been
wish i had stayed
came back really when she would have
stayed wish i would have why
because it's typically the other way
around what she would have i you know
acting was something i loved i grew up
in a house where my mom taught acting
classes to kids
and out of my living room when um when i
was really little she taught
improvisation and i loved it i genuinely
loved it i write about this in my book
dear hartley a little bit trying to
encourage my kid to like if you love
something go for it don't be a coward
like me
but it was hard and i was in la i was
with a friend and
i just didn't have the right head and i
i didn't give it my best shot and i
think if i would have stayed i would
have had at least a chance either i
would have had a chance at success or i
would have been able to say i gave it my
all which is always what you want out of
life and you want your kids to know that
too so pat asked you who you were in
high school 10th grade yeah so you know
you kind of you brought up the can like
so were you a melrose place girl 90210
with luke perry rolled up on you rest in
peace i loved him so much yes 90210 100
all the way i was a brenda dillon fan
loved him got to meet him at the view
years later oh my gosh he was like your
husband was in the crowd he was looking
a little nervous my husband was a little
jealous i wasn't married at the time
yeah and you were having second thoughts
and my mom said to me that my
now husband looked at her and said
should i should i go up there and she
was like jeremy it's live television
like what are you going to do up there
knock out dylan mckay because i was like
i was very back
but yeah i was 10th grade i was also ran
track i was you know i was social but
i'm not social now this is the most
social i get what's happening right now
jedi were you feisty like were you like
were you part of the debate team were
you part of like all of that or not
really i was quite when i was really
small i never spoke in fact my first
grade teacher called my mom and was like
is she okay and she's really smart but
she doesn't speak i was very shy and
very afraid of all of that
by the time i got to high school i had a
teacher a politics teacher who i later
found out was like a super liberal but
really encouraged us to to speak out and
i kind of got my voice in that class
um and in college kind of shifted away
did more of a literary journey but i
think that was where i kind of got my
fire
and you know years later after i did the
acting came back to new york taught for
a little while the whole the whole
political career started because i was
writing on a blog that had like five
viewers i'm not kidding at one point it
was like five people had seen my article
and one of the articles was reviewing
mark levin's book
and my friend sent it to him and he read
it on air
and a couple of months later like sean
hannity's people called me and we're
like does she want to come on the panel
and my mom fainted because my mom loves
him to this day
hannity and i there i was this school
teacher who didn't have a journalism
degree who was a regular girl just
speaking my mind
sitting on a panel and two weeks later
filling in for dana marino in a segment
with stuart varney and i was like i'm
not really sure how
i think there was just a hunger for a
regular voice at that time well ron paul
said the best thing ron paul said
when he was doing what he was doing
full-time as a doctor he started going
and hearing a uh economist speak
he says when i left every time he
recommended a book i'd go back and read
the book i'd go back and read it now i
said i got obsessed he said so i kept
going back every time he was giving a
speech he said eventually i went up to
the guy said listen
i can't help myself i'm addicted to this
content this just makes a lot of sense
liberty freedom all this stuff he said
this was never things i thought about he
says what do i do with this passion he
says don't worry about it he says keep
talking about it keep writing about it
the right people will find you people
found you so
was fox found you first because the mark
living and then the view came in how did
that how did you approach it so fox
found me first and i wound up doing a
lot of free television which is what
happens in tv everyone sees that you're
on tv and they're like oh you're a
celebrity
you're broke i was broke i had been on a
teacher's salary before that i don't
come from money i grew up in a very
middle class family my parents struggled
to pay the mortgage you know i
didn't have that i didn't have any
connections to the political world like
my parents weren't in politics um
so i did a lot of free tv and then i got
my first contributor deal
over at fox after maybe a couple of
years of doing free television i did not
only free tv at fox i was doing you know
cnbc i was doing um with larry kudlow at
the time i was doing msnbc hits kudlow i
mean that's
serious
conversations right there no i mean
yes but not mine mine were more like
culture we'd do a panel or but i would
find myself in these places and be like
wow i'm building a career but broke
nobody knows this maybe i should have
told everyone hey make a donation make
it till you make it girlfriend exactly
exactly and i got my first contributor
deal first contributed was small i mean
it's not money that you're making but
you know from there i was due i signed
two deals with fox that were for a
contributor and then the view came
and it's funny i went to roger ailes at
the time and i said you know the view
wants me to come on and guest host and
he typically fox doesn't let you do any
of that stuff but he was like well
i think it'll be really good for the
network you know extra exposure and
you're not gonna get the job
no way yeah because i was so new i was
so green and i was like okay you know i
knew i had a shotgun did you take that
as a challenge or was it just kind of
like are you like i'm going to crush
this one show when i get on they're
going to know i belong here well once he
gave me in writing the approval i was
like wait till he sees what i do
did he become your pat talks about find
your enemy to get motivated right did
that become your enemy proving roger
ailes the legendary great you know
controversial i think your enemy well i
think it was he had launched this huge
television network and you know for a
while i had been i had been a
contributor but i wanted to fill in on
shows like i wanted to host and he was
always like you know you have to earn
your place to do that and here comes
this network tv show that's like we'll
give her a chance and he was like oh you
don't you know almost like
she's too green and i went i got the job
so
i love it i love when people are
underestimated so when you go at what
point did they just tell you right there
listen we want to talk no i had to test
there too which i was fine to do because
i was employed i had my fox contract and
i would show you the view i did a few
months of testing um with a bunch of
people that were testing i remember like
um
melissa joan hart was testing i i was it
was like a lot of celebrities at the
time yeah what are they asking you i'm
curious like when they're sitting there
they're interviewing you what can do
they ask you like so what do you think
about this what do you think is that
kind of a conversation i did an
interview first with candy carter who i
really like she's still at abc she's a
nice she's really nice fun um
and i she asked me a zillion questions
like how do you feel about this and how
do you feel about that and they wanted
you know the claim was that they wanted
diversity of thought on the panel and
they wanted someone who was going to be
tough
to stand up to the other opinions so it
was a very long interview and i left and
i was like i don't know what happened
like i don't know and then she was like
all right we're going to put you on so
they put me on oh it was long it was
like i feel like i was in there for like
a couple hours honestly it was long and
you said it's a panel or it's just candy
well it was just me and candy for the
interview and then um
i think i met with candy i think i met
with brian uh i met with a few people
and they were like okay green light her
let's put her on and see what she does
so i was this girl who had
just a couple of years before that been
writing for a vlog like
five what was the timeline but yeah by
the time levin brought you on you're on
hannity a couple of years okay so you're
putting some but you've got no but you
gotta realize couple years not a long
time people have to this is very
important for people that are listening
to this look
you know whatever situation you're in
with your life like sometimes
people like the part she talked about
she did so much free tv you know that's
the part a lot of people don't want to
do you're gonna have to work and get
underpaid for a long time until you get
your break
and she got a break it's a beautiful
story that's exactly how capitalism
works
that's exactly how your world works
that's how business works we you know
you pay the price and then they find you
and it goes back to ron paul's story if
you keep talking about what you believe
in they're eventually going to find you
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you